[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn I've been using Express VPN
for a few weeks now and I find it to be
a very reliable way and very fast way to
make sure that my data are secure and
encrypted without slowing down my
internet speed whatsoever it's very easy
to forget that I even have it on but
first why should you care about
encrypting data at all and rule number
one or reason number one I should say is
it's often quite easy for a hacker to
bypass Wi-Fi security and steal your
information and I've seen this
demonstrated by friends of mine who know
how to do this and it's terrifying
they can exploit flaws like crack and
many others if you're interested in
checking that up you can google crack
with a KKR ACK if you ever use public
Wi-Fi at say a hotel or a coffee shop
where I often do work and where many of
you my listeners no doubt do work you're
often sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption whatsoever one way
to ensure that all of your data are
encrypted and can't be easily read by
hackers is by using expressvpn all you
need to do is download the Express VPN
app on your computer or smartphone and
then use the internet the web just as
you normally would you click one button
in the Express VPN app to secure 100% of
your network data expressvpn is also
recommended as the number one VPN
provider by review sites like TechRadar
and CNET expressvpn is a company that
takes privacy and security to the next
level they invented a technology called
trusted server to ensure that no data
logs are written to a server's hard
drive even by accident trusted server
all onward was recently audited by PwC
this PricewaterhouseCoopers to confirm
how its technology protects your privacy
if you want one of the best solutions in
online security and privacy protection
head over to expressvpn comm / Tim for
an exclusive deal expressvpn is offering
three extra months free with a one-year
package to all of my listeners who visit
expressvpn
dot-com / Tim protect your internet
today with the VPN I use to keep my data
safe go to expressvpn comm slashed him
to get started this episode is brought
to you by Business Wars what's that it's
a podcast people always ask me what
podcast I listen to and the truth is I
don't listen to that many just a handful
because most of my bandwidth is taken up
with producing my own podcast one
exception in other words one that makes
the cut is business warrants from the
podcast network wondering of course
human history has thousands upon
thousands of epic wars and that is
existed forever but some notable wars
are waged between businesses whether
between gigantic corporations or between
tiny tiny startups and large incumbents
David and Goliath situations and
business wars which I've been listening
to just listen to it this morning in
fact on my ride to downtown Austin takes
you right into the middle of these
battles sometimes the prize for these
competitors is your wallet or your
attention sometimes it's just the fun of
beating the other guy the outcomes of
these battles shape how we live what we
buy and often what we think I've
listened to previous episodes and
previous seasons so for instance I have
listened to Netflix vs. blockbuster it
was amazing Nike vs adidas also
incredible but there are also of smaller
businesses and many different types of
folks profiled the sound design is
incredible I didn't think it would
matter to me but it really does in the
newest season which I've been listening
to is about the WWE's that's the World
Wrestling Entertainment's long road to
success and battles with the WCW and
just as one surprise did you know that
the World Wrestling Federation now the
WWE started as just one of 30 regional
wrestling associations
and the first episode so this is WWF
versus WCW Titan rising and a lot of
strategy comes out of this a lot can be
learned about how to do battle in
business but here's the description it's
the early 1980s and there's peace in the
wrestling business for years regional
wrestling companies and maintained order
by sticking to their own slices of US
and Canadian territory but all that's
about to change
Vince McMahon has just taken over the
WWF and he wants war he's on a mission
to crush all opposition and establish
the WWF is the only wrestling game in
town but his assault on the wrestling
status quo will also make him a powerful
enemy cable TV mogul Ted Turner I had no
idea about this backstory and it's great
so definitely check it out it's hosted
by David Brown a former anchor of
marketplace who is really fantastic so
David as we're listening nicely done
might ping you about future audio books
and it is an immersive sound design
experience you'll see what I mean when
you check it out that shares the untold
and very real stories of what went on
behind the scenes with now broadly
speaking the leaders executives and
investors and what led them to new
heights or to ruin or sometimes
somewhere in between you can find
business Wars on Apple podcasts or
wherever you're listening to this
episode right now or head to Wonder EFM
slash Tim that's wo ND e ry dot F M
slash Tim TI M that's where you can find
business worse it's a great show I
suggest starting with the latest series
it's really good even if you don't care
about wrestling whatsoever I mean as a
child of the 80s it was always somewhere
in the culture for me but it's great
also as a sort of business strategy
tactic art of war type of discussion
latest series WWF vs. WCW it's a pretty
epic one filled with all the colorful
cast of characters you would expect Hulk
Hogan there's some amazing archival
audio of TV shows this Hulk Hogan
appeared on actually choked one anchor
unconscious accidentally it's pretty
[ __ ] crazy story pardon my french
Stone Cold Steve Austin and many others
so check it out
wonder EFM slash Tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where does my job to deconstruct least
attempt to deconstruct through
interviewing world-class performers
their habits routines lessons learned
etc and my guest today is none other
than Lisa Ling who is Lisa Ling
award-winning journalist lisa lange is
the host and executive producer of the
CNN original series this is life with
Lisa Ling which is currently in its
sixth season and you can find that at
least this season premiering on
September 29th that is a Sunday at 10:00
p.m. Eastern and Pacific this is life in
each episode Ling immerses herself in
communities across America giving
viewers an inside look at some of the
most unconventional segments of society
2017 the series won a Gracie Award
laying is also host of the CNN digital
series this is sex with Lisa Ling which
explores the taboos around sex in
America and this is birth with Lisa Ling
which explores how healthcare
legislation income equality and cultural
shifts shape how people have children in
America she has a very illustrious
career we're going to talk about it in
the course of our conversation but
suffice to say from The Oprah Winfrey
Show to Nightline to national
Geographics Explorer she's reported from
dozens of countries covering stories
about all manner of things including
many topics that are neglected or
ignored in mainstream media gang-rape in
the congo bride burning in India and the
Lord's Resistance Army in Uganda just as
a few examples and we talk about the
sort of emotional toll that that can
take and many of the complexities of
covering some of these extremely
difficult topics Lynn got her start in
journalism as a correspondent for
Channel One News where she covered the
civil war in Afghanistan at 21 years of
age another experience we all talk about
she later went on to become a co-host of
ABC's daytime hit show The View which
won its first Daytime Emmy during her
time at the show she also served as a
special correspondent for CNN s planet
in peril series and is a contributing
editor for USA TODAY's USA weekend
magazine 2011 her acclaimed documentary
journalism series our America with Lisa
Ling began airing on own
she's also an author she has co-authored
mother daughter sister bride rituals of
womanhood
and somewhere inside one sisters
captivity in North America and the
others fight to bring her home which she
penned with her sister Laura 2014
President Obama named link to the
Commission on White House fellows you
can find her on twitter at lisa lang on
facebook facebook.com slash ling and
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Lisa Ling
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did
Lisa welcome to the show thank you so
much and this has been in the works for
a while so I'm very pleased to finally
be having this conversation and we have
a lot to cover or certainly many
questions that I would love to ask so
I'll start with age 21 Afghanistan was
that your first time in Afghanistan that
definitely was yeah I was 21 and and and
never in my wildest dreams did I ever
think that I would go to a place like
Afghanistan at that age or ever but it
was certainly as you can probably
imagine one of the most eye-opening
things that I've ever experienced to
this day and did you at say the end of
high school think that that type of
correspondent work is what you'd be
doing or did you have other thoughts in
your mind for what you were going to be
post graduation you know when I was a
kid we didn't grow up with a lot of
money and I always been an insatiably
curious person
even as a young young you know kid but I
really didn't have the opportunity to
travel that much and so when I was 18 I
was hired to report for a show called
Channel One News which was a show that
was seen in schools across the country
in fact Anderson Cooper was one of my
colleagues and they sent us off into the
world to cover far-flung stories in
distant locations and one day there was
talk amongst some of the executives
about sending a correspondent to cover
the civil
or in a country that at the time I
couldn't even identify on a map and it
was Afghanistan and I agreed to go
because we'd be going in with the Red
Cross and so the likelihood of something
happening well with the Red Cross would
be far less and had I not gone in with
them so I agreed and from the moment I
set foot in Jalalabad Afghanistan I just
you know realized I was very very very
far from home what was say the first 48
or 72 hours of that experience like for
you I mean as a 21 year old you're still
very malleable I mean your personality
is certainly developed to some extent
but at that early in the nascent point
in your professional life what were the
first few days there like for you well I
had never I'd barely traveled by the
time I was 21 and so as cliche as this
sounds I felt like I was on another
planet Afghanistan at the time had I
mean it was really like a country that
had been just completely destroyed it
was in in rubble really there were
bullet holes and and and craters
everywhere not a single wall stood that
wasn't riddled with bullet holes because
when I was there in the early 90s it was
in the midst of a civil war but before
that for about a decade it was the scene
of a war between Afghanistan and the
Soviet Union during which time my
country the United States pumped
billions of dollars worth of weaponry
into the hands of the Afghans to fight
our then enemy the Soviet Union and so
here I was you know in a place that my
country had a major major role in it had
a role in everything that I was seeing
around me so many of the young boys that
I was looking at we're carrying
american-made weapons because they were
paid for by the United States but yet I
knew that back home no one had
a clue that this scene existed in the
world so it was just it was just surreal
I mean I kept closing my eyes and
opening my eyes and just going where the
[ __ ] am I and how did I end up here
I mean honestly because it was just you
know the furthest place on earth that I
could have ever imagined
you have since covered so many different
topics subcultures problems and more I
mean the Venn diagram if I were to try
to draw it out would be really
remarkable and the question that has
come to my mind so many times and this
is true also after spending time with
people like Sebastian Junger for
instance how have you handled after
covering say gang rape in the Congo
bride burning in India and so on the
emotional toll of some of these subjects
I mean are there any stories that you
can share about contending with that
because I would have to imagine that it
hasn't all been easy to digest yeah I
mean I definitely have been witness to
some of the worst aspects of humanity
I mean covering a story about gang rape
in the Congo what you mentioned covering
stories about bride burning in India
stories about child trafficking and just
just really devastating and horrifying
aspects of humanity and and I I don't
always handle it well you know I am
lucky that I'm not out there on my own
covering these kinds of stories I'm
always with a team and when we are out
in the field we are truly living the
story we ever you know every second of
the day is consumed by the story and I
meet people and people share with me on
so many occasions things that they
haven't even shared with their closest
friends or family members and so as a
result you can't help but build a bond
and develop a relationship with these
people
and I try to give everyone that I meet
my cell phone or that I that I profile
my cell phone because again like they've
just shared the you know the depths of
their heart with me I would be remiss if
I were to just say okay thanks for
sharing by you know like I we just
shared something really powerful and so
staying in touch with people has really
helped me I mean I've gotten you know
fairly decent at compartmentalizing like
you know my work is my work and I'm
deeply deeply passionate about it but it
sort of exists for me in one part of my
heart in my brain and then my family and
my life are another part do they do they
do they ever get fused absolutely all
the time and a my my husband my family
they know that sometimes I just need
some space to just decompress and
process but what keeps me going honestly
is just knowing that bringing a lot of
these stories to light will raise
consciousness among you know ordinary
people who may feel compelled to do
something about it or just become more
aware of these issues on their own so
I've a few follow-up questions
the first is do you have any stories of
becoming enmeshed with some of these
subjects and people who have suffered
when you provide say your cell phone
which is a very human and humane thing
to do simultaneously it opens up the
door to I would imagine all sorts of
potential complexity oh yeah I mean I've
I've gotten calls from drug addicts said
at at you know all hours of the night
I've gotten calls from prison many many
calls from prison and and and there is a
risk there was an inmate that and this
wasn't this wasn't someone I gave my my
cell phone number to but we you know we
had this really personal exchange while
I was interviewing him
and I mean it was really like he really
revealed so much about his life and what
propelled him to you know become the man
that he became and do what he did and so
he started writing to me and I would
write back to him and after a while you
know I just you know life life took over
and it became increasingly more
difficult to keep up you know our our
pen pal relationship right and so one
day I get a letter in the mail and he's
threatening me with violence because I
stopped all right I hadn't written to
him in a long time and that was
certainly a moment I mean and it wasn't
just it wasn't just like I'm gonna kill
you it was like a really really
terrifying thing that he said
and III thought about reporting it but I
didn't and subsequently a couple of
months later he wrote me another letter
apologizing profusely but it was one of
those moments where I thought you know
maybe this wasn't such a good idea to
maintain this relationship I mean that
was you know the only it was the only
time something like that happened for
the most part I get asked for money from
time to time particularly from people
who are abusing drugs or I get asked to
help and you know in different ways and
I try to do what I can and I tell people
that I I will do what I can but I also
make it clear that you know I can only
do so much
that sounds very difficult I mean what
would what do you say to say a drug
addict who's asking for money who
perhaps you've helped which might in its
own way set a precedent or an
expectation what what do you say to
someone who's asking for something like
that that you can't continue to provide
well look Tim I mean I've I've bought a
lot of bus tickets for people and I I am
though very open now and I and I I did
learn
hard way because you know one of the
guys that I was buying bus tickets for I
found out later on that he was
continuing to use and so now I will say
to people look I just had just to make
things clear I'm not going to give you
money I'm never going to give you money
because I don't know really what you're
going to do with it but if I can help
you in any way if I can direct you to
resources I will I will do everything I
can to try to do so and I and I really
do I mean again I I do take
responsibility for these relationships
and they're important to me and they're
personal for me and I really do care
about these people because of this thing
that they shared with me and that we
shared together but I do have to be very
careful because when when when it comes
to money
I realize especially when someone is
under the influence that I can be very
easily taken advantage of yeah it's it's
a balancing act er it's ooh it seemed to
be and I remember at one point
befriending this homeless man in San
Francisco where I used to live and at
one point paid him to give me a tour of
the sort of homeless economy and the
homeless underground in San Francisco
and he was entirely coherent it was
actually a fascinating and really
eye-opening experience and I mean the
homeless situation in San Francisco is
absolutely terrible for many reasons and
later not that much later something like
72 hours later he had my cell phone and
had a complete psychotic break and was
just making no sense whatsoever and it
was really gut wrenching because he
seemed to go from periods of lucidity to
complete detachment from reality and I
was very unsure of how to even approach
helping someone like this which may be
beyond the scope of our conversation but
well but it really you know it puts in
perspective for me always the work that
social workers do I mean you know they
are on the front lines of all of this
stuff right and they they
so in many cases you know become deeply
entwined with with people and you know I
think the difference between people like
you and me is while we may establish
relationships we don't really know how
to deal with you know people who are in
the throes of addiction or who are
mentally ill you know and if it's you as
much as you want to try and help people
there there certainly are risks that
need to be taken seriously as well so
let's let's talk about personal risks
and you mentioned decompressing and
processing earlier could you speak to
perhaps a particularly challenging
experience it doesn't have to be related
to the television work but it certainly
could be and how you processed and
metabolized something that was very
difficult because it seems like there
have to be instances where as much as
you can compartmentalize you can't unsee
things or unhear things that come into
your perceptive field and how do you
metabolize that say some of the more
difficult experiences years ago I
interviewed a 17 year old girl named
Ashley who was sold into the world of
sexual commercial sexual exploitation
when she was like 11 years old she was
basically sold by a cousin to be able to
be a prostitute and I I remember you
know we were we were I had an all-male
team and I asked them all to sit outside
so that she and I could have a more
candid conversation we were we were in a
bedroom so the only man in the room was
our cameraman and the two of us and as
she was recounting her story I remember
her telling me about how at 11 years old
she would on a regular basis call the
police and begged them to arrest her so
that she could have a safe place to
sleep and Tim it was just like it was so
gun gut wrenching the way she was
telling the story and from outside of
the room I could hear my male colleagues
going like starting to cry and then I
just totally lost it and she ended up
having to console me because I had just
been so overwhelmed with grief and after
that interview my team and I we just
kind of like huddled together and just
we all cried together
again like this is five men and me and
we just we just had to let it out it was
it was just so devastating and you know
I mentioned earlier that having these
teams who are are with you along the way
has really been my salvation because if
I were alone doing this I I don't know
that I would have been able to survive
all these years because it is so
emotionally taxing but but having these
people you know by my side and and
really my team consists of the most
sensitive incredible people men and
women has been what has has has gotten
me through all of it and hopefully I've
been able to help them get through it as
well but it just makes you realize like
how how much people are hurting out
there how how deep and dark people's
worlds are which by the way is is why
I'm so excited about all the work that
you're doing and in psychedelic research
because I think that it's just to ignore
this possible pathway to recovery
from from trauma and grief would be just
a a colossal mistake given how much
people are hurting yeah thank you yeah
there's there's a tremendous amount pain
out there and it's part of the reason
that I'm also so
respectful and encouraging of the
incredible work that you do is that
you're sharing stories that at the very
least help
ay-ay-ay not so small subset of the
population to know that they are not
alone and the type of suffering that
either they've experienced or that they
have felt because loved ones have
suffered and that I think that's a
that's a very very important ingredient
in the in any recipe that will begin to
resolve or mitigate some of these
whether it's trosset ease or just simply
conditions that are debilitating yeah
and to be honest with you what I really
hope that people will do when they when
they watch my work any of my shows it's
just to feel something you know I think
we have become this culture that doesn't
want to feel and it's really easy for
doctors when we're going through things
that are hard to say well here's a pill
to take but you know let's hit and take
some edge off let me let me give you
something and for me the one one of the
main reasons why I I love what I do so
much is because I I like to feel whether
it's it's it's it's feeling you know
heart sick or feeling Glee like
recognizing what it's like to feel it
just makes me feel more alive my senses
are heightened and I I feel grateful
that I'm able to have this kind of
experience irrespective of the feelings
that are generated and unfortunately we
just we're afraid of feeling and I think
that it's it's becoming increasingly
dangerous and so you know I hope that
people when they come and see my work
they they will be prepared and ready to
feel but I also hope that they will come
with an open mind because we will often
profile or immerse ourselves among
people that
you would otherwise never get a chance
to get to know or you might not want to
get to know but hopefully we will give
you an opportunity to know people who
are different from you and and and
develop a better understanding of our
fellow humans it's a fantastic objective
and I think also it's important to note
that most of the important conversations
that need to be had are not going to be
comfortable right and I'd like to ask a
follow-up related to feeling and in the
process of doing research for this
conversation I read and feel free to
fact-check this because I can't believe
everything you read on the internet but
I had read that your family was not
particularly communicative as it related
to sex or dating or emotions and
specifically I'm interested in that last
part because many people listening even
perhaps someone talking like me comes
from a family where there were certain
things that were off-limits or there
were certain things that just weren't
discussed and perhaps feelings and
emotions were in that category if if
that was true when you're growing up how
did you train yourself to feel or to
discuss emotions more openly it's a
great question I come from a pretty
traditional Asian family and most people
probably have a pretty decent sense that
Asian culture is is just not the most
communicative and on top of that my
parents got divorced when I was seven
years old and I grew up mostly with my
dad and who worked all the time and so I
always felt very conflicted about my my
my identity you know I didn't like being
Asian because I was in a community that
was totally non diverse I didn't I I
felt a lot of resentment toward my
parents because they weren't active in
the way
my friends families were and so in my
late teens early twenties I I decided
that I needed to get help because I just
I I had all this stuff kind of
percolating in my in my in my body right
in my in my soul in my heart but I
couldn't identify exactly what I was
feeling I didn't really even know what
feelings were and so I started working
really hard with a therapist and just
talking and that therapist started
asking me about my relationship with my
mom and my dad and and to tell you the
truth I didn't know anything about my
parents
backstory because we didn't talk about
it and so when I took the initiative to
try and learn about my mom in particular
because we didn't have much of a
relationship when I was a kid I just
just became astounded by her backstory I
ended up taking her to Taiwan back to
where she grew up and it was a really
painful experience because she did not
have a good childhood I mean it was very
very dark the things that that she
experienced but it allowed me to know
her and all of that resentment that I
felt for her just disappeared because it
was almost like I was looking at this
little girl and what she had to deal
with as a little girl and it made my
issues just seem so trivial even though
they weren't but they compared to what
she went through and I think that really
propelled me to want to understand
people better because at the end of the
day Tim you know we all are human beings
right we were all born of parents who
who who loved us we were all born of a
mother at one time right and and we're
learning so much about about when kids
experience any kind of trauma between
the ages of one and seventeen when their
brains are developing the fastest well
if you don't address that trauma if you
don't deal with it then it can go on to
haunt you for the rest of your life and
and emerge in ways and get triggered in
ways that that you might never expect
and for me I just after that experience
I started to really try and dig deep and
it made me a better a better person it
made me a better reporter it made me I
mean I've always been a curious person
but I think it really kind of ignited
this this has come this empathy thing
because I just I start thinking about
everyone as like a little boy you know
and I and in so many cases when I
interview people I ask them to go back
to when they were seven or eight years
old and and I asked them how they would
feel if they could see their
eight-year-old self could see them right
now and what they would say to them and
the truth is that we all you know we all
experience something as a child that
really has continued to live with us and
in some cases haunt us or debilitate us
but until we take take steps to address
it it could continue on and so for me
doing this kind of work that's always
something that you know I kind of keep
in the back of my mind like really
trying to understand like how this
person you know got to this place how
this person became the way he or she
became thank you for sharing that this
is this is really important and at least
I think it's important and I'd love to
I'd love to dig into getting to know
your mom did you sit down whether over
the phone or in person and effectively
interview your mom about her backstory
or or was it more intuited traveling
together how did you unravel that story
I would imagine it would be very
uncomfortable if you to have a
relationship beforehand or much of one
very much so you know I started to just
ask her some questions and I could see
that some of the questions I asked her
like I could just see her her body
change you know like a simple question
like how would
you described your childhood or were you
happy as a kid and you know when you
were seven years old like what did you
what did you want to be you know what
was your what was your day-to-day like
when you were an eight nine year old
child and when she would go back to that
period Tim it was really like I'll never
forget how she went from you know this
adult you know my mother who was
supposed to be the protector of me
became this little girl and it was
really hard for her to even answer those
kind of simple questions like what was
your childhood like and it propelled me
to you know want to know more and so you
know I wasn't I didn't have a lot of
money at the time but I knew that this
was going to be such a necessary
investment for me and and and for my mom
too because it was obvious that she had
never talked about a lot of this stuff
and so we took this trip to Taiwan and a
lot of it was really painful a lot of it
was amazing because it was just the two
of us having this journey and and we
kind of shared intimate moments that
we'd never shared before his mother and
daughter and you know two people out
there listening if you if you've never
taken the time to really understand your
parents lives
I would I would really urge people to do
so because it's really it will it will
bring people so much more clarity as to
like who their parents really are and
and and why they have made the decisions
that they've made I really want to
underscore how much I agree with that
and have seen the type of conversation
you're describing which can be very
uncomfortable completely change how my
adult friends operate in the world and
relate to their and their family meaning
not just their family parents but their
family spouse kids
etc because perhaps on some level if you
have unresolved resentment not to say
that this conversation will resolve it
all but if you have some degree of
resentment towards your parents your
childhood and your ability to parent and
so many other things that may be sort of
below the liminal layer of awareness
it's it's really remarkable and I've had
some very open conversations with my
parents in the last few years that if
you had asked me 10 years ago if I would
ever even contemplate having these
conversations I would have brushed it
aside as completely impossible
and and it's it's it's given me a level
of relief that I couldn't have predicted
beforehand well I think it's
particularly critical for men to do this
because I I do feel like right now there
are a lot of young men and men who are
feeling feeling crisis right now you
know the you know whether it's the job
market or you know the me2 movement or
whatever I you know I I you know the
suicide rate for example is is is
skyrocketing among men and I think that
for so long men have been told to not
feel or to not to not show emotion and I
think that igniting that process of
getting to know your parents or your
your you know your father for young men
I think it's just a really important
thing for for people to really do
because young men really need permission
to be able to feel and so many men feel
in crisis right now because they've
never been given that permission to to
feel definitely and I would say also
that
if if anyone listening is is perhaps
saying to themselves as I did for a long
time well I just don't want to deal with
it right I don't want to open that
Pandora's box like I've put it behind me
I've compartmentalised what what I would
say at least in my experience is you're
gonna deal with it no matter what the
question is are you going to deal with
it in a conscious productive productive
way where you face it head-on or are you
gonna compress it into a box and allow
it to seep out the edges and strange
ways where it manifests as you were
getting easily pissed off or yelling at
your kid or whatever it might be because
one way or another you are dealing with
it and my experience has been it's
really trying to figure out what your
coping mechanisms are and if they're
maladaptive causing you further harm or
adaptive in some positive way and the
the the question of therapy is one that
I'd like to return to how did you find
your therapist oh if that's a tough
question because I don't even remember
her I and I suppose the the the attack
I'm taking is how might you suggest
people find a therapist if they've never
even entertained the thought before
right but so it can be a
self-referential or it could be just a
broader discussion of therapy yeah well
unfortunately in our culture you know
our healthcare system is not conducive
for people to find therapists or even
have insurance cover therapy which i
think is so it's it's so ass-backwards
in every possible way and and that's why
so many doctors are just prescribing you
know pharmaceutical drugs - you know for
people - to band-aid or put a bandaid on
their pain and so what I would say to
people is you know check with your
insurance plan see if it's covered
somehow or if a part of it is covered
and I think people are hesitant
to spend money on therapy because it's
it's not cheap you know therapy is
expensive but I have to say that
investing and therapy if if you if your
insurance is prohibitive you know and
and and you can find therapists that are
less expensive than others it's such
such an important investment because
you're investing in your future you're
investing in your mental health and you
know and there's things that just
shouldn't be those are things that
should not be ignored and if you
absolutely can't afford therapy you know
if you have a group of friends and and
particularly for men again like men
aren't they're not conditioned they
weren't raised to be communicative and
emotional with with other men but if you
can get a group together regularly once
a month if you once every two months to
just like talk and let down the guard at
you know convey that it's a it's a
completely private
you know conversation no one outside of
the room should know what what it said
but you know people need that outlet to
be able to just release you know whether
whether your friends offer you
constructive you know advice or
criticism is almost irrelevant you just
need to have a release in a safe space
to be able to just kind of express your
feelings it's so healthy to do that and
and I I'm so emphatic about trying to
convey that message because right now
we're all humanity is just so addicted
to devices that we're not connecting
with people you know it's ironic we're
so connected with the world you know we
can find out any score to any game at
the tip of our fingertips but we're more
isolated and lonely than ever because
we're defaulting to these devices and
not communicating enough with human
beings I mean
remember when we were kids and we would
call you know when I would call that boy
that I had a crush on those feelings
that it would evoke my God I would get
so nervous and like you know I would
like to start breathing heavily and it
would take like an hour for me to get up
the nerve to make that call like those
are those are those are really important
feelings to experience and we've just
like totally done away with all of that
because we're now existing in just like
swype culture right and we we don't even
have those opportunities we don't allow
ourselves those opportunities to even
feel anymore and I think that that is
you know it's really dangerous because
if you don't have those outlets and you
just default to those devices you can
find those dark communities and dig
yourself even deeper into a hole and so
the extent that you can seek out human
contact put the phones away and just
like sit in a room together without
phones see if you can even do that smile
at each other you know like just have
some human contact yeah agreed
and I'll what I'll do also is take a
number of therapy services and for those
people who might be more constrained
financially some apps as well that are
related to therapy and I'll put them in
the show notes so for people listening
you go to Tim top blog for such podcast
and just find this episode and I'll put
those in the show notes for people right
you mentioned earlier the sort of male
demographic increasing suicide rates as
a trend line I'd like to talk about some
of your female influences extraordinary
women who have perhaps influenced you
you you've spent time with some
incredible people and I mean just to
name a few Oprah Winfrey Barbara Walters
what if you what if you picked up
observed or learned from some of these
incredible women you've you've had the
opportunity to spend time with you know
it's funny because all my life as a
young person I always fancied having a
lie
like Barbara Walters or Oprah Winfrey
and so when I got a chance to actually
work with them and you know sit at a
table with them and and and look to my
right and see them it was just it was
surreal like I I was just I I had like
outer body experiences whenever I'd look
to my left and I'd see you know look
into the eyes of over Oprah Winfrey and
I remember I was always a really
ambitious young person and I and I I've
always been kind of a sponge that likes
to absorb as much wisdom as I can about
how to be a better reporter or how to be
more successful right and every time I
interacted with Barbara Walters the
first thing that she would ever ask me
is you know are you taking care of your
personal life are you neglecting your
personal life are you taking time for
your personal life and I remember I was
young when I started working on the view
I was in my mid-20s I would always think
to myself like I want to talk about how
you got the interview with Fidel Castro
or Monica Lewinsky or how did you do
that you know but now in retrospect
looking back I learned so much from
these women about because I look what
Barbara was doing was basically telling
me that she did those things she
neglected her personal life you know in
pursuit of her career and I could tell
that there was a hole left in her and I
remember when she was was retiring from
from ABC she you know Barbara Walters
has interviewed everyone but she said
her biggest regret was not spending more
time with her daughter and and I think
back on that and it makes me really sad
because I so idolized her and wanted a
life in a career just like Barbara
Walters and the most important lesson
that she taught me was to not neglect my
my personal life and and I and I will
cherish that advice because I was
someone who never wanted to have kids I
never had that biological desire
I've been married for 12 years in six
years into our marriage my husband said
well why don't we just try and I thought
huh I don't really want to but you know
if it's something really important to
you we can just we can try and then I
got pregnant pretty quickly and then I
had a miscarriage and then I got crazy
and I'm like I want to have a kid you
know because I met type-a you know like
how do I win at pregnancy failure I had
to overcome that I mean it was really
sick and twisted but now I look at my
children I have a six and a
three-year-old and even though they
drive me crazy and at forty six years
old I think to myself like what am I
thinking with a three-year-old but I
just I'm so grateful to people like
Barbara for telling me to not you know
neglect my personal life because they
are just they're everything to me and
everything that I do now in my my work
and in my life is to try and make this a
better place for for them
and to try and bring people together and
ignite dialog especially in this period
of just ugliness and hostility because
I've always just believed that the more
we know about each other the more we
will respect each other and the better
we become ultimately so what I want to
ask a little bit more about advice and
then we'll segue to some other spots
including the sort of the the hustle of
Lisa Ling but we'll get to that in due
time before that as you were telling me
this story about Barbara and her advice
to you it made me think of a story that
I heard from the writer Neil Gaiman and
when he was exploding in popularity due
to the The Sandman series of graphic
novels Stephen King told him at one
point enjoy it because he had these long
lines of people waiting for signatures
and so on and Neil could admit that at
the time he was not able to take that
advice he did not save her
it was very stressful for him is there
well a were you able to take Barbara's
advice at the time that you heard it or
did it take a while to like course
correct and take that into account and
then is there any other advice you've
received that you were able to take but
later realized was very important at the
time when Barbara you know kept asking
me those questions and almost like
reprimanding me for because she could
tell that I was just so ambitious that I
I was not really devoting time to my
personal life I I didn't I didn't take
it seriously but now I just every time I
look at my kids you know I'm just so
grateful that I was able to have them I
mean I I had a number of miscarriages
after the first one and I definitely
went through periods where I thought
that I might not be able to have kids
but I am so I'm so grateful that I have
them because they they not only are you
know my life I mean everybody loves
their kids and everybody considers their
kids their life but they really have
made me want to do the right thing for
them you know and leave this place
better for them and to do everything
that I can to you know like it sounds so
cliche to him but like make the world a
better place for them and and so you
know as we are kind of again like in
this period of just hostility and
ugliness and darkness and our you know
the people that we are supposed to look
up to are you know our politicians our
business leaders in so many cases are so
morally bankrupt it makes me more
defiant than ever to want to ignite
dialogue and to give people a way to get
to know their fellow humans better I
just you know I
feel like what I do is a job I don't
really think about it as a job I just
think it's something that I'm supposed
to be doing right now and and to do it
well as hard as as is the case with so
many things and I'd like to talk about
access and being able to cover some of
the groups and stories that you've been
able to cover or bring a voice to in
terms of stories so again this is
quoting from the internet so who knows
but this is a quote that I have in my
research I fancy myself as a bit of a
hustler I'm a very persistent person I
can be aggressive in my own way you have
to be constantly you have to constantly
be pushing to get the stories that you
want told told so you couldn't you can
tell me if that sounds roughly like
something you would say and assuming
assuming that it is more or less
accurate what are the keys to getting
the type of unprecedented access to
groups that you've had so much success
with well yes I I I certainly have been
aggressive throughout my life and my
career about trying to get access but in
recent years since we've had this show
this is life on CNN on the air for the
last six seasons six plus now I think
that people have gotten a good sense of
our show and a good sense of me and it I
think if you if you're a regular viewer
of our show you see that I am NOT a
sensational or exploitative person I
like to think of myself as you know the
vehicle through which people can
experience other cultures or communities
that are different from theirs and over
time I think that people have
have started to recognize that if they
are going to share their story on a show
ours would probably be a good one to do
it because we do give people an
opportunity to tell their stories I mean
at the end of the day irrespective of
what you may have been accused of or or
or how you may live your life we are
going to give you a chance to tell your
story I might ask you some tough
questions but ultimately this show that
we do is really about giving people a
chance to to share and and I try really
really hard to be as non-judgmental a
listener as I can and as far as
catalyzing conversation getting people
to think differently or take action of
some type do you have any success
stories that come to mind for you that
have made their way over the transom
somehow after people have seen the work
that you've that you've done these
various interviews and and programs that
you've put out into the world
well Oprah was certainly when I was a
correspondent for her show I mean it was
pretty remarkable what she was able to
do when I reported in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo a story about gang
rape and just these women having to
endure the most unfathomable horrors I
think in in two airings of that segment
over three million dollars was raised
for the organization that helped me do
the story that was providing aid to
these women and that just that really
showed me the power of Oprah I mean it
was it was unbelievable I don't know
that there will ever be that kind of
force for good as Oprah and and I really
I really miss her on television because
she really I think elevated humanity and
and brought things to light that
otherwise like no television outlet or
media outlet would touch for me
our shows are you know less shows about
you know activism our shows really are
an exploration of different worlds or
subcultures or different different
issues and just you know people coming
up to me constantly and just saying I
had I had no idea that you know that
that black Muslims you know are had such
a big presence in in this country and
that the women actually feel very
liberated by being able to wear a hijab
because they don't feel the pressure of
having to show their bodies are using
their their their their bodies to
influence anything you know I mean I
think just just people expressing their
enlightenment their enlightenment or
their just that they they they learned
something from something that I've done
like that is really satisfying and
fulfilling for me I think it's a real
service because you're offering people
the opportunity to stress test a lot of
their assumptions and to broaden their
picture of reality to accommodate
first-hand reports from people that
might conflict with whatever stories
they've kind of fabricated or inferred
from sensational news headlines and so
on right so yeah I mean a couple seasons
ago we did something about gender
fluidity and we profiled a man named
Steve who was starting to dress in
women's clothing and and and Steve told
me that he'd he'd always wanted to like
he always felt this connection with his
feminine side but you know because we
live in a culture that has never
welcomed it in fact to the contrary was
really you know you know he felt like
had to suppress that feminine side he
never he never you know would wear
women's clothing out like he he always
felt like he he was more gender fluid
than not and so so I was in a room with
him as he was putting makeup on putting
earrings on he put a dress on and I
literally said to him Steve
I have to be honest with you if I saw
you walking down the street randomly I
would probably look at you like oh my
god like what what what is going on like
that guy is a freak like I my eye I
might like just be predisposed to have
that feeling but having spent time with
him getting to know his story you know
just like getting inside his head
allowed me to see him so differently
that that whole you know exterior the
dress the makeup it was it was almost
like that was what he was supposed to be
wearing like I saw him know differently
in lipstick and earrings and I did an
hour before when he was just talking to
me as Steve and a t-shirt and jeans and
it just goes it's just like such a
testament to this idea of listening
people and hearing people out I'm as
guilty as the next person of just
following the people on Twitter who
espoused the same beliefs as I do you
know it's so easy I watched the media
that espouses what I what I believe and
it's it's it's easier than ever to exist
in these silos and so what I'm trying
really hard to do in life but also in my
show is break out of those bubbles and
and really hear our people out and
understand how other people live because
that's the only way that we're going to
be able to you know come to an
understanding
politically or socially like we can't I
can't see us existing this way forever
it's just like it's too volatile yeah
absolutely is and the more that we can
at least be exposed to samples of
profiles like you're providing where we
can see the sort of inherent complexity
may not be the right word but I'll use
it for lack of a better stand and so the
complexity of each human as this
tapestry of emotions and feelings the
the harder it is to to paint with a
broad brush and hate someone because you
view them as one issue right you you
view them as a walking opinion that you
disagree with but when you start to
flesh that out as a portrait you realize
that the vast majority of that person is
shared it's a shared experience that you
also have absolutely Tim I mean you know
when we worked on a piece about the
ms-13 gang you know the the gang that
present Trump has you know called
animals right and and and yes they have
as an organization committed unspeakable
atrocities and and and you know have
committed the most violent acts
imaginable but if you you know and and
this is not in any way to condone that
savagery but when you take the time to
understand the kinds of things that
these people were exposed to in their
home countries or the pressure they may
have been under to do what they did
it doesn't make you or doesn't make me I
should speak for myself feel sorry for
them it doesn't make me condone what
they've done it doesn't make what
they've done right in any way but it
gives me the ability and the opportunity
to try and figure out how to prevent the
next young person who may be exposed to
the same things from going down that
road unless we can identify
like where that behavior comes from and
what those people were exposed to it's
it's it's not going to make it any
better just to call them animals and try
and hunt them down you know you have to
you have to attack it at its its root if
you're ever going to be able to make
real progress yeah definitely looking at
causes and not just symptoms it's it's
very easy to discard or kind of brush
away yeah yeah it's just easy to
characterize a group of people as
savages who need to be punished at all
at all caught yeah it sort of absolves
you of the responsibility of thinking
which doesn't ultimately solve anything
Lisa what is up next I believe that you
have now season six is that right this
is like what what is season six have in
store what are split are some of the
topics that you'll be exploring and also
where can people find it so our show
this is life is on CNN it premieres on
September 29th a Sunday and will air on
CNN every Sunday thereafter our first
episode is called poor necks because so
many young people are getting their sex
ed from pornography and porn has always
always been around but now the ease of
access any kid with a device or access
to a vise a device can access unlimited
amounts of porn and it's having a
devastating impact on on an entire
generation and the way they perceive sex
and relationships we're also doing a
piece about benzodiazepines so we're
talking about valium ativan xanax
klonopin these are medications that are
used for anxiety if you're not on them
you probably know people who are and
they are medicines that should be used
for very short periods of time but
there's a whole generation of people
who've been on them for years
and it's a highly highly addictive drug
and there is a fear that benzos are the
next opioids we also explore women in
the Marines they've been the last branch
of the military to allow women to to
participate in combat and we embedded
with the Marines at Camp Pendleton we're
doing an episode about swingers because
swingers aren't what you think they are
they've now evolved into like an entire
lifestyle that just welcomes free sex
and we also have an episode about this
gang in Mississippi it's the
fastest-growing gang in Mississippi it's
a white gang although they're not a
racist gang but we understand why we
attempt to understand why that gang is
growing so fast in the state of
Mississippi how do you choose your
subjects I mean you have the ability to
canvass extremely widely to pick groups
and subjects how did you end up deciding
on on some of these well it very
randomly actually I mean I I'm a pretty
voracious reader and consumer of
information and we will generally pick
about 20 topics and present them to CNN
and they will approve eight eight of
them for us to pursue but for me it's
really about exploring worlds that are
just different from me that I think
people would find interesting you know
that the porn Edie episode and the
benzos episode to me there are two
issues I think people need to know about
you know as far as the pornography
episode is concerned like parents need
to wake up and and acknowledge the fact
that the moment they give their kids a
device they have unfettered access to
you know extreme kinds of pornography
even if they have really rigid filters
on their devices I mean you're basically
giving your kids a supercomputer to have
on their bodies and so there are some
issues that we take on that I just think
people need
to know about yeah the porn is is tricky
I mean the parental controls I saw a
tweet I won't mention his name just in
case he wouldn't appreciate it but he
put a tweet recently which said you know
my wife sent up parental controls for up
for the forgot the password needed my
son to figure it out now she has to ask
him for the password to log into the
parental controls to watch television
and it's it's a it's a it's a very
challenging I would imagine situation
where you have digital natives who by
almost every measure are more savvy with
technology than the parents who are
trying to implement controls sure very
very challenging well you know we in our
episode we feature a adult film actress
who's on a mission to tell porn
consumers that it's fantasy and that
what you don't see is that before
cameras even started rolling they
negotiated what they will and will not
do and they had a conversation about
consent you know what what what kids can
access I mean you you don't see people
talking about consent you know or
negotiations or women exerting any kind
of power at all we also spend time with
a woman who created this website called
make love not porn where she shows real
people having real world sex which means
like they're not perfect body types
there may be mistakes there may be you
know it may get messy but she thinks
that we need to start seeing what what
real sex really looks like and not you
know this artificial porn that is is
heavily produced and and plays on in
most cases your your wildest fantasies
because it's just not real and it's it's
damaging kids minds what was the hardest
episode and you can interpret that
however you like hard could take many
different forms but what was the hardest
episode on some level for you to get
done this this season
well the the benzos episode made me the
most pissed because I I started to
realize that this class of medication is
one of the most widely prescribed on
earth yet doctors in many cases don't
know how to get people off them if they
are starting to exhibit symptoms of
withdrawal
I talked to a very high-ranking
psychiatrist at Stanford in the Stanford
Medical School and I asked her when you
were in medical school did you learn how
to deal with benzo withdrawal or did you
learn how to get people off of these
medications she said no this is a
psychiatrist at Stanford and now you
have general practitioners you have
internist you have pediatricians
prescribing these drugs for an
indefinite period of time it's just it's
it has made me infuriated because
doctors are the people that we entrust
with our safety with our our lives and
they in many cases don't don't realize
how to treat the symptoms of these drugs
yeah it's it's such an important point
that you know before you start taking
any medication and unfortunately this is
incumbent upon the consumer which is
very unfair but nonetheless
caveat emptor to figure out what the
termination clause looks like in the
sense that
having a having a clear understanding of
what the physical dependence can be if
you take any drug right which is reason
for instance you know I have my my
girlfriend had a really bad injury some
time ago and we have an unused bottle of
tramadol at home and I was like you know
what I want to get rid of this right
away because having in the house is a
liability and a lot of these drugs are
so powerful but because they're common
the incredible potency in some cases for
good therapeutic effect but often for
devastating negative effects are really
underestimated I mean my best friend not
too long ago died of a fatal combination
of fentanyl and alcohol because a friend
of his said oh you have a headache here
take this gave him fentanyl and
this this friend meaning the guy who
gave it to him had developed a very high
tolerance because he was an opiate user
my friend had never used opiates and
fell asleep and didn't wake up and these
are just because something is common
does not mean that it is extremely
dangerous if misused or abused or simply
used for a long period of time so I look
forward to seeing that episode yeah I
mean I really really hope people tune
into this because you know isn't it
isn't it curious that these medications
are so widely prescribed yet you know
our culture is more anxious than ever
you know like that's the the irony in
all of this yeah yeah this I I I
remember speaking as moderating a panel
on psychedelic science which which you
mentioned earlier at the Milken Global
Conference and I asked two questions
before starting and one of them well
I'll tell you both questions the first
was raise your hand if you know I can
statement raise your hand if you know
anyone who's taking antidepressants and
is still depressed every hand in the
room like 400-500 went up and then I
asked them this is a pretty muckety-muck
crowd keep in mind right and I asked him
do you have you personally or do you
know anyone who has been affected by
opiate addiction raise your hand and
again every hand in the room four
hundred five hundred went up and it just
it it really begs the question you know
are we treating are we treating causes
and do we have a system that allows for
the treatment or the investigation of
causes or are we simply masking the
symptoms of dis-ease that that we really
haven't taken the time to properly
understand so it is a very very
important subject well yeah and that's
again that's why I
laud you for really taking on you know
the psychedelic therapy because I think
that it could you know under the right
guidance right in conjunction with with
with therapy I think it could be really
revolutionary and allow people to kind
of like open up those pathways that have
been closed up for so long and I'm just
honestly I am absolutely terrified of a
lot of these pharmaceutical drugs but
what terrifies me even more is that a
lot of the doctors who are prescribing
them don't really know like really
really know the consequences and how to
help people get off of them if they find
themselves dependent on them yeah that's
terrifying
well I hope that the broader awareness
generated by the episode will will
catalyze some different thinking and
maybe some different action by perhaps
regulators or at the very least
physicians who are prescribing these
medications yeah i mean i i i i say in
the episode like the one thing that I've
done because I've gotten medicine
prescribed and I get the literature and
I just I don't even open it but I I
realize now that it's incumbent on me if
I'm going to put something in my body I
need to look it over and if I have any
questions whatsoever I need to ask we we
all need to be doing that more regularly
you know we have to take the initiative
even though I do believe it's a doctor's
responsibility to really know what he or
she is prescribing we also need to take
responsibility and read through the
literature when we get it yeah
absolutely I want to change direction
for just just a couple of minutes
because I know we have limited time left
and we're gonna come back to this is
life but you mentioned earlier that
you're a voracious reader are there any
books in particular that you have gifted
often to other people in the past
the book that I have gifted the most
often it's you would not expect this of
me but it's it's called Genghis Khan and
the making of the modern world fabulous
book fabulous book you've read it isn't
it it's incredible so much well because
I think that history has portrayed
Genghis Khan is the ultimate raper and
pillager of the universe but what people
don't realize is that his Mongol army I
mean he was he was one of the world's
great democratizer z' and that the only
way the Mongol army was able to take
control of most of the world in 25 years
it took it took the Mongols 25 years to
conquer the amount of territory that it
took the Romans to conquer in 250 years
was that the Mongol army would go in
they would take out the aristocracy and
give the the the the the the lowest
level citizen right the slaves in some
cases an opportunity to rise up within
his army khaleesies character on Game of
Thrones I heard was based on Genghis
Khan and when you look at you know if
you were to look at his army it would
consist of people who in some cases had
blond hair and blue eyes because he
conquered so much of of Eastern Europe
but that's a story that I think also in
this period of class divide is really a
moving one because he was this character
who you know was a slave at one time
himself went on to conquer two-thirds of
the population of the earth because he
elevated you know people he elevated
slaves and the lowest level of human to
rise up in his army I'm really glad that
you brought this book up it's it was it
was recommended to me by I won't mention
it by name but when one of the
best-known CEOs in the world and I
thought it was kind of a strange
recommendation at the time because I had
the same I had the same assumptions
about
Genghis Khan and then came to read this
book and the story of the author himself
is also fascinating because he went back
and traced these historical paths and
what you really come to appreciate is a
the magnitude of this Empire that was
built compared to like you said the
Roman Empire is just one example and and
also how surprising many of the
realities are of this this army and the
leadership style or the conquering style
of Genghis Khan and so much as as one
example the freedom of religion that yes
was not just allowed but encouraged but
the as I haven't read this book in a few
years but as I remember at the the one
caveat was you you can continue to pray
to all the gods that you want to pray to
as long as you also pray for Genghis
Khan which seem very fair seem very fair
but that's that's a fantastic but
definitely it's so good and like you
would not think you know when you hear
the term democratizer vows you know the
the the greatest among us who ever lived
with someone who has been reputed to be
such a you know a villain in history but
that was all contrived to you know his
portrayal in the portrayal of the Mongol
army was all contrived so it's just so
fascinating to read and it's I I cannot
tell you how many people I've gifted
that books it just just just to also be
clear I mean he his army was excellent
at killing people I mean there was that
but not so it was not as one-sided a
story of a roaming horde of sort of
foaming-at-the-mouth savages that any of
the other portrayals would have you to
believe is very sophisticated in in in a
lot of respects so I I second that
recommendation
are there any other books that you've
gifted or recommend it to many people
I mean I I also love the alchemist it's
one of my favorite yeah yeah you know
just just following the journey of this
shepherd boy to far-flung you know
corners of the earth was just such a
like a fantastical journey for me you
know though he realized that like you
know that that the most fascinating
place was inside of him you know and the
most thoughtful important place was
inside of him like I just will always
that book will always have a very
special place in my in my heart it's
such a such a fast read such an easy
read and I remember reading that when I
was I want to say first traveling I
didn't travel much at all when I was
younger and it did have a lasting impact
and the story behind that book also I
find very encouraging because and I
might get the numbers wrong but I
believe that Paulo Coelho the author
yeah had an initial print run of
something like 500 copies and then that
first publisher gave up on the alchemist
shelved it and yet later republish it
and of course now it's sold a hundred
million plus copies well I didn't even
know that story it's yeah it was not
simple little book profound
yeah and one more book even though I
haven't gifted it to a lot of people but
it is I credit this book with propelling
me to dig deeper and to not always you
know believe the narrative and that book
is a people's history of the United
States by Howard Zinn mm-hmm this is one
I haven't read so told tell me if teller
or you you have to read this book
because it will turn on its head so much
of what you have always believed to be
true about this country you know it it
goes into graphic
tale the savagery that took place you
know with with Columbus with Christopher
Columbus on the native of Native
Americans the native people who
inhabited this land I mean it just it
just forces you to rethink everything
that you've learned and to think about
it in another context and it's it is
it's a profound experience to to read
this book and think about it in in the
context of history I love it
well incredible I will and I know you
know what I love about the two of the
three examples that you gave much like
the show I suppose so it shouldn't be
surprising is that these are these are
the art these are assumption and
narrative testing books and you know I
would I would say that you know if you
find yourself say for any given week
having the day-to-day experience of not
having uncomfortable conversations or
reading things that make you
uncomfortable not in a mudslinging
capacity but in the sense of deeply and
legitimately stress testing beliefs or
narratives that you have about yourself
or the world or other people then you're
really not living properly as far as I'm
concerned because so much of what we
tell ourselves is just utter [ __ ]
it's complete complete nonsense and as
soon as you start to stress test it it
just falls apart it's like the the
wizard behind the curtain in The Wizard
of Oz so I'm really glad that you
mention these and I will pick up
Howard's book and and and when you read
that book you will I mean everything
that you just said it's after you read
that book you'll go okay now I get why
she responded to this book because your
jaw will be dropped and again like
everything that you learned in school
you will think differently about it
you'll you'll think about this other
perspective and I think it will change
the way you view our institutions
I think it'll change the way you think
about what it means to be an American
and and you know hopefully it will
strike a chord with you and you will
like just feel more empathy because of
you know like how this country was like
the way this country was founded yeah
empathy man we could definitely use a
heavy dose of more empathy and and I
think one of the ways that you develop
empathy in part is by through allowing
and even encouraging your own believes
to be tested developing more flexibility
in how you perceive the world and other
people right accurately and because you
know the more labels you apply to other
people and yourself
the Dumber you become to borrow a Paula
Graham and paraphrase a Paul Graham
expression and it's it's true I think
this productive discomfort of reading
things like this or watching television
shows like those you put out that you
develop a cognitive flexibility that
opens the door to emotional development
in terms of empathy it's really really
good
hey it's easy to live in a bubble and to
be told what to think and then and then
spew what you've been told that's that's
easy right it's it's it's it's hard to
try and you know understand the truth or
take the time it requires time and
energy to get invested in other people's
stories but I do in my heart of hearts
believe that you emerge a better and
smarter human as a result of taking that
time it is in no way a waste no no and
it's
it's it's it's deeply positive it's also
deeply practical right at least in my
experience and what I've observed if you
if you don't have any empathy or you
have very minimal empathy for other
people who are labeled your enemies or
the other party or whatever it might be
that's also reflected and I think how
you treat the people around you
including the people you love most and
not excluding yourself so you know how
you treat others as you would have them
treat you it goes the other way around
as well and I think that how you how you
relate to the world and treat others is
also often mirrored and how you relate
and to and treat yourself so this is a
deeply positive I think it makes you
more adaptable and it's it's also very
practical from an emotional health
perspective they say that that empathy
is a key driver in success you know some
of the most successful people you know
have have have you know had that had
those those you know characterizations
or could be characterized as as being
empathy I mean there's a direct
correlation between empathy and success
but yeah I mean and I think that it's
also you you you you can develop empathy
to you know it's it's it's not like it's
something that you're born with right
and I think for young people for any
parents who are who are listening with
this or just young people who are really
attached to their devices I think you
know take that time as I mentioned
earlier to just like put it away and
have conversations with people like
really really connect with people on a
human level I think that the further we
get away from that you know the further
we get from you know being able to feel
empathy and I think a great example of
one of those conversations is the
conversation that you had with your mom
and the steps that you took after a
childhood which is very common for many
people listening of not discussing
emotions
through therapy through this
conversation with your mom and so on
creating access to your own emotions and
greater awareness of your own emotions
naturally led you to a greater
development of empathy towards other
people because I know I'm yeah I know
I'm a better person as a result of that
experience and ultimately I do think I'm
a better mom because of it because I I
recognize how much it benefited me to
take the time to understand you know my
mom's past it was one of the most
important life lessons for me yeah I
would imagine your kids are going to
benefit tremendously from the effort
that you took in having some very
uncomfortable conversations at the time
and let me ask just a few more questions
I know we're coming up on time shortly
this is this is a hard question so you
can sort of tackle it from any angle you
like but the Billboard questions so if
you could put a message a quote and
image anything non-commercial on a
billboard metaphorically to get
something out to billions of people
let's say does anything come to mind
that you might put on such a billboard
you know the thing that I think would
speak to these times would be like stop
texting and start listening mm-hmm yeah
because I I just I feel like so much has
gotten lost in this digital this digital
culture that we are you know living in
yeah
yes indeed I think we're very poorly
poorly designed for the environments
that we have created for ourselves from
DJ yeah and I mean you know and and and
I need to practice what I preach because
I'm on my device a lot I try really hard
now to put it away when I'm at home and
if I have to do some work on it I'll
tell my my kids like I'm gonna go
upstairs and do another room because
it's just it's rude for me to be on my
phone in front of them all the time
and how can I expect them to not be on
the phone all the time when you know
they get their devices one day or when
their parents one day so I I try really
hard and I am as guilty as the next
person of you know going down that
rabbit hole of social media late at
night you know just like an hour will
elapse and I'm still on Instagram and
feeling really shitty about myself
because I've just looked at these
perfect lives of people you know and and
look like I'll be honest there have been
you know dinners that I see my friends
posting about that I wasn't invited to
and I feel this like pang of like why
wasn't I invited to that you know I
definitely have felt that and I'm
thinking to myself I'm an adult I can
get over this stuff pretty quickly but
for this young generation of kids that
you know is growing up with this like
not getting invited to you know a party
and not just any party because you don't
just post any party on Instagram you
post like the sickest party you've ever
been to on Instagram right and not
getting invited to that like what does
that do to your ego you know it's like
the thing I hated the most about high
school was just like I remember that
kind of obsession I had with popularity
you know cuz I think all young people
think they want to know what their
places they want to have friends and you
know they they want they want to be
popular social media is every like that
which I hated about popularity and high
school magnified and just you know I
think that we all need to just like put
it aside from time to time
and just like breathe and really really
connect with people so like the message
that that my billboard you know would
contain would definitely have to do it
with just like you know connecting with
humans mm-hmm well you do a good job of
showcasing that in in the work that you
put out and you have this season sex
this is life yeah on CNN premiering
Sunday September 29th 10 p.m. Eastern
and Pacific and for the since we just
mentioned social media people can find
you on Instagram correct me if I'm
getting any of this wrong Lisa Ling
Instagram that's your handle Twitter at
least I'm sorry go ahead
Lisa links to Graham oh there we go yes
Lisa Ling's cigarettes Wow okay yeah so
okay I will link to that just to save
people the the spelling challenge
Twitter a little bit bit easier at Lisa
Ling is that right that's right and then
you've got we've got the website to this
life which I'll link to in the show
notes Facebook is it facebook.com slash
Ling yes all right it is and I and I try
hard to you know read a lot of the
messages that I get but I'm not great at
it because I've been trying really hard
especially when I'm around my kids to be
present with them and you know I am
going to start taking bigger breaks from
social media because I just you know I
think we all need to just have those
breathers and I hope people will do that
along with me yeah yeah social media
will still be here when you get back so
it's not going anywhere for better for
worse I at least give anything else you
would like to add any suggestions
comments any any parting words before we
wrap up I mean I think we covered a lot
i I think you're great and I'm I hope we
can work together in some capacity maybe
on psychedelic stuff yeah I would love
that
I would love that I'd love to be a be a
resource help in any way I appreciate
that you're out there having really
thoughtful conversations with people you
- you - is you've been doing this long
before this podcast is even an idea in
my head so you've you've paved the way
and provided a really inspiring example
no doubt to so many people who have then
wanted to emulate what you do which is
providing a full human picture in
subcultures and related to topics that
can be polarizing or uncomfortable and
that's that's a very important service
in the world and it's hard for me to
imagine at least as long as I've been on
this planet a more important time for
that type of influence to exist offset
so much of the terrifying sort of
polarization that exists in the world
right now so thank you for doing what
you do thanks Tim likewise and so I
think this is a natural place to close
so thank you very much Lisa
and to everybody listening you can find
links to everything we've discussed in
the show notes as usual at teamed-up log
forward slash podcast and just look up
Lisa Ling and it will come to your
fingertips and until next time thanks
for listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday's a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
business Wars what's that it's podcast
people always ask me what podcast I
listen to you and the truth is I don't
listen to that many just a handful
because most of my bandwidth is taken up
with producing my own podcast one
exception in other words one that makes
the cut is business warrants for the
podcast network but wonder II of course
human history has thousands upon
thousands of epic wars and that is
existed forever
but some notable wars are waged between
businesses whether between gigantic
corporations or between tiny tiny
startups and large incumbents David and
Goliath situations and business wars
which I've been listening to oh just
listen to it this morning in fact on my
ride to downtown Austin takes you right
into the middle of these battles
sometimes the prize for these
competitors is your wallet or your
attention sometimes it's just the fun of
beating the other guy the outcomes with
these battles shape how we live what we
buy and often what we think I've listed
the previous episodes and previous
seasons so for instance I have listened
to Netflix vs. blockbuster it was
amazing Nike vs Adi is also incredible
but there are also smaller businesses
and many different types of folks
profile the sound design is incredible I
didn't think it would matter to me but
it really does and the newest season
which I've been listening to is about
the WWE es that's the World Wrestling
Entertainment's long road to success and
battles with WCW
and just as one surprise did you know
that the World Wrestling Federation now
the WWE started as just one of 30
regional wrestling associations and the
first episode so this is WWF versus WCW
Titan rising and a lot of strategy comes
out of this a lot can be learned about
how to do battle and business but here's
the description it's the early 1980s and
there's peace in the wrestling business
for years regional wrestling companies
and maintain order by sticking to their
own slices of US Canadian territory but
all that's about to change
Vince McMahon has just taken over the
WWF and he wants war he's on a mission
to crush all opposition and establish
the WWF is the only wrestling game in
town but his assault on the wrestling
status quo will also make him a powerful
enemy cable TV mogul Ted Turner I had no
idea about this backstory and it's great
so definitely check it out it's hosted
by David Brown a former anchor of
marketplace who's really fantastic so
David as we're listening
nicely done might ping you about future
audio books and it is an immersive sound
design experience you'll see what I mean
when you check it out it shares the
untold and very real stories of what
went on behind the scenes with now
broadly speaking the leaders executives
and investors what led them to new
heights or to ruin or sometimes
somewhere in between you can find
business Wars on Apple podcasts or
wherever you're listening to this
episode right now or head to 1 3 mm
slash Tim that's wo ND ER Y dot F and
slash Tim T I am that's think about
business worse it's great show I suggest
starting with the latest series it's
really good even if you don't care about
wrestling whatsoever I mean as a child
of the 80s it was always somewhere in
the culture for me but it's great also
as a business strategy tactic art of war
type of discussion latest series WWF vs.
WCW it's pretty epic one filled with all
the colorful cast of characters you
would expect Hulk Hogan there's some
amazing archival audio of TV shows The
Hulk Hogan appeared on actually choked
one
Anker unconscious accidentally it's
pretty [ __ ] crazy story with my
French Stone Cold Steve Austin and many
others so check it out one dree dot F M
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by expressvpn I've been using a press
VPN for a few weeks now
and I find it to be a very reliable way
and very fast way to make sure that my
data are secure and encrypted without
slowing down my internet speed
whatsoever it's very easy to forget that
I even have it on but first why should
you care about encrypting data at all
and rule over one or even number one I
should say is it's often quite easy for
a hacker to bypass Wi-Fi security and
steal your information and I've seen
this demonstrated by friends of mine who
know how to do this and it's terrifying
they can exploit flaws like crack and
many others if you're interested in
checking that up you can Google crack
with a k' k ra c k if you ever use
public Wi-Fi at say a hotel or a coffee
shop or I often do work and it where
many of you my listeners no doubt do
work you're often sending data over an
open network meaning no encryption
whatsoever one way to ensure that all of
your data are encrypted and can't be
easily read by hackers is by using
expressvpn all you need to do is
download the expressvpn app on your
computer or smartphone and then use the
internet the web just as you normally
would you click one button in the
expressvpn
app to secure 100% of your network data
expressvpn is also recommended as the
number one VPN provider by review sites
like TechRadar and c net expressvpn is a
company that takes privacy and security
to the next level they invented a
technology called trusted server to
ensure that no data logs are written to
a servers hard drive even by accident
trusted server all onward was recently
audited by PwC this
PricewaterhouseCoopers to confirm how
its technology protects your privacy if
you want one of the best solutions in
online security and privacy protection
head over to expressvpn comm slash Tim
for an exclusive deal expressvpn is
offering three extra months free with a
one-year package to all of my listeners
who visit expressvpn
calm / tip protect your internet today
with the VPN I use to keep my data safe
go to express cbn.com / Tim to get
started
[Applause]